&gt;&gt; Hi I'm Sandra D'souza. &gt;&gt; And I'm Chris Aiden. &gt;&gt; Welcome to class, I love
math and I can't wait to show the wonders of algebra with you. I've been
teaching math for over 7 years and this is a totally new experience for me as it
is probably for you. I hope you're as excited as I am about what's to come. &gt;&gt;
This course is broken into 12 units. Each unit consists of lessons with a series
of videos. &gt;&gt; You will find interactive questions within these videos, as well
as practice problems at the end of each lesson. The purpose of these questions
is not to test your intelligence, it's to make you think. &gt;&gt; Here's an example
of what you can expect. &gt;&gt; Which of these do you think successful students do?
Check any of these reasons that apply.